I'm Gwyneth Paltrow hi I'm Emma
Chamberlain hi I'm Catherine Heigl I am
Kylie Jenner hi I'm Mila Kunis and this
is everything I eat in a day and this is
everything I eat in a day and this is
everything I eat in a day I'm Abby sharp
and this is everything I eat in a day I
want to hop in here super quick to tell
you about my sponsor today hungry root
so when I'm down south in the states
with my family I'm really just trying my
best to relax I mean 2023 is proving to
be an insanely busy year so I try so
hard to spend as much time as possible
with the kiddos while they're on holiday
and that means spending as little time
as possible cooking meals because moms
know they're probably just gonna check
them on the ground anyway so hunger root
has made meals so much easier for me you
basically take a short quiz about your
dietary needs and goals and then hunger
root will send personalized weekly
deliveries packed with healthy groceries
sometimes including 10 minute recipes
plus a bunch of fun snacks for on the go
I've actually discovered a bunch of
really cool snacks and products that my
kids love so I am loading up on those
every week week but hungry root is
different from other grocery delivery
services because they send you recipe
inspiration to make with your haul but
you're also encouraged to mix and match
based on what you feel like that night
this has significantly cut down on meal
prep grocery shopping and food waste and
I've gotten some really great
inspiration for meals that have since
become regulars in rotation so if you
want to try out hungry root for yourself
be the first 100 people to use my promo
code Abby 40 and you'll get 40 off of
your first order the first thing I do
when I wake up is
respond to like my kids screaming mama
mama
at the top of their lungs
we go through faces with these kids
where they wake up for the day at like 5
30 and then other faces where maybe
they'll go back to sleep until like 6 30
6 45 7. it's a nice surprise and I
usually don't even know what to do with
the time but regardless I almost always
get a hauler before 6 a.m because like
I'm a nightmare the world is a nightmare
someone has to pee a teddy bear fell on
the ground the pillows like facing the
wrong way whatever so after that initial
wake up I'm basically awake for the day
um and I'll hide under the blankets
looking at my phone so as not to wake my
husband up unless he's doing the same
thing and I don't look at emails until I
start the work day and I also try to
avoid Tick Tock and YouTube because they
stress me out so I try to just stick to
my personal Facebook and read like baby
announcements and look at puppy photos
it's a bunch As relaxing as scrolling
through social media as a content
creator can be and once my kits are up I
will wash my face brush my teeth put on
my house coat that's like my work from
home uniform basically and I make the
kids breakfast and I drink a few cups of
water just plain basic tap water no
lemon not alkaline like whatever's
around whatever's convenient sometimes
it's like a half drank half flat San
Pellegrino hydration it's a beautiful
thing and then I have my first coffee of
the day I usually do like a soy latte
with a splash of this like nut pods
creamer thing it's really delicious and
to all the holistic nutritionists on
Tick Tock will tell you you should never
have coffee first thing in the morning
on an empty stomach I have covered this
like a million times on my channel if
you drink coffee regularly it's not
gonna totally up your hormones and
if it bothers your stomach have it with
with a snack or try making it like a
latte as I do if it's not broken don't
fix it so I used to eat a pre- breakfast
but I do find my digestion is better
when I don't and I'm also just not
hungry in the morning anymore probably
because I'm sleeping better thank you
sleep meds anyway I take the first shift
with the kids and then my hubby and I
swap so that I can get in a quick
workout since covid I haven't even been
to a public gym at all and I kind of
love that right like I do a lot of
YouTube workouts at home so I love
Pamela Reef I love mad fit City Cummings
plus I just use all the different apps
like Peloton to kind of like switch it
up I milk my alone time hour like right
down to the second at which time I have
to like Rush upstairs just in the nick
of time to throw the kids into the car
and take them to school then I'm back
just after like 9am which is when I get
to kind of sit down and have a proper
quiet child-free meal alone so I'll
usually make myself another latte a big
one usually one shot of regular espresso
and one shot of decaf and then I'll take
all my supplements and medications too
many to list most of which are for
anxiety and IBS and then I'll throw
together a simple but like really
satisfying breakfast I like never want
to dirty a pan on a weekday because I
just want to get to sitting down to work
so some of my favorite breakfasts are
like protein oats with like lots of
berries on top I also always add cereal
for crunch I need that like textural
contrast and then I'll usually pair that
with a few pieces of toast or like whole
grain waffles with some hemp hearts and
peanut butter and honey and banana like
I like to go all that with the toppings
but if it's not protein oats I'll then
do Greek yogurt or cottage cheese and
like layer it like a parfait again I
don't want breakfast to take more than
10 minutes max including cleanup so
really whatever is easy to just throw
together is what I make so I'll take a
few minutes to just sit down quietly in
the kitchen at the bar with my coffee
and my breakfast while kind of making a
game plan for the day in gen zedspeak we
could call this like setting my
intentions for the day if I'm filming
with my team
it's basically a super chaotic eating
day so all my typical meal times can get
a little messy and spontaneous but if
it's an office day where I'm writing or
I'm having meetings I'll go to my office
and I'll get to work and I generally
don't have a morning snack anymore
because again I just feel better when I
space out my meals meal spacing helps to
support the migratory Motor complex
which is really important for folks with
a history of functional gut disorders
like me so my next meal is usually lunch
which happens around 12 30 1 o'clock and
again I don't like to spend time cooking
in the work day so basically I always
have any leftovers from the night before
so if we had like chicken or tofu maybe
I'll make a wrap with the leftovers or
if we did like turkey sausage with like
potatoes I'll just warm that up if I
have leftover roasted veggies from
dinner that's my preference for lunch
because cooked veggies are just easier
on my gut but if not I will just throw
together like a super simple salad with
whatever greens I have in the fridge any
batch prepped veggies that I made for
the kids and I like a huge handful of
cheese you gotta have like a ton of
cheese
um nuts a little balsamic vinaigrette
and then I'll just serve that up with
the leftover protein and carbs I also
just like feel the need for something
sweet in my mouth at the end of like
basically any meal and this is called
mouth hunger and it's totally normal and
should be honored without judgment so
sometimes I have a few spoonfuls of ice
cream sometimes it's just like I need a
handful of Juicy grapes or an apple or
like shove Dry Cereal into my mouth it
can really range just based on what I
see first and what feels good when I
imagine it in my mouth
that's what she said this is one of many
reasons why I just could never go low
carb like carbs give me emotional
satisfaction even when I'm already like
physically satiated so if I just have
that basic salad with no carbs for lunch
I would need a lot more than a few bites
of ice cream afterwards because I would
be longing for that emotional
satisfaction so yeah carbs for me are
key my go-to cheat meal oh yeah no
no I don't believe in cheat meals
Harper's Bazaar I'm gonna flip the
script here like I really think it
creates this black and white thinking
around food and scarcity mentality so I
basically just try to work fun Foods
into my daily diet I'm a dietitian I
think obviously foods are not
necessarily always going to be
nutritionally equal but we can still
make them morally equal and calling some
foods clean and others like a cheat
insinuates moral value But to answer
your question in like a slightly
different way if I had no regard for how
food made my body feel or how it
affected my energy levels or digestion
Etc my favorite meal would be a baked
mac and cheese with like a really crispy
panko crust like oh you gotta have that
crunchy crust with like the super ooey
gooey Center oh like whatever the normal
ratio of sauce to Noodles is you gotta
double it up so like you gotta have a
lot of cheese sauce then I would do like
roasted brussels sprouts with some
chilies and honey and like a little
bacon in there and a glass of really
cold Chablis or sancer and
sticky toffee pudding for dessert I
don't always have these things all at
once but I do have each of them
regularly enough that there's really no
desire to see any of them as a cheat
dinner
so
I used to be a really adventurous cook I
loved coming up with really unique
recipes and I would spend like over an
hour cooking a multi-course meal for
myself and my husband and then I had
kids so yeah dinners are pretty simple
around here because I basically have to
serve everything deconstructed family
style so that my kids can have their
safe foods and they can have some new
options to explore and we try to switch
it up but like most families we have our
favorites so an Abbey staple meal as my
husband would call it is actually a
recipe that's in my book mindful glow so
I will roast or grill or pan fry some
chicken or turkey sausages there's
actually not a lot of options for good
chicken sausages in Canada but in
America man you guys have more chicken
sausages in the store then I have half
drank San Pellegrino in my house
and trust me I got a lot of those but
anyway I do the chicken sausages and
then I get a head of red cabbage I shred
it up like really really fine and I
braise it with some diced Apple like
some balsamic glaze a little maple syrup
and some Dijon mustard if I'm
entertaining I'll do it with some crispy
bacon bits in there because it
definitely makes it better but it is a
whole other step and it's still super
delicious without it then I make what my
son calls Mama potatoes so I parboil
some like baby really cute like new
potatoes and then I half a quarter them
depending on the size and I pan fry them
in a mixture of avocado oil and butter
until they're really golden brown and
crispy and then I like finished off with
flaky salt honestly my kid will eat an
entire plate and I'm not mad about it my
favorite food cities so people don't
know this but before I was a YouTuber I
ran a a restaurant centered food blog
like way back in the OG blogging days so
I had the privilege to dine at some like
really incredible restaurants around the
world including a lot of really kind of
fancy Michelin star spots and my
favorite restaurants were always the
ones that had kind of more molecular
modernist elements because obviously I
can't cook like little olive oil Pearls
at home on a Tuesday for myself so if
you watch that new movie the menu on
Disney plus is like stuff like that
minus the bloodbath details I think some
of my most memorable experiences were
like 11 Madison Park in New York City
um lazy bear in San Francisco Super Fun
uh mugaritz in Spain olinia in Chicago
and the fat duck in the UK oh the fat
duck has this dish that's like Alice in
Wonderland themed and I've always really
been enamored by that story so that meal
was like particularly super special for
me lots of good memories but honestly
these days I just do not have the same
stamina to make it through a four hour
meal with wine pairings nor could I
justify that expense and also I have
kids now so date nights are a lot more
low-key but yeah I'm still super
grateful I got to have those experiences
while I could snacks
I love snacks and like snacks to me
doesn't mean junk or packaged Foods
necessarily they're just small meals to
bridge bigger meals but because of my
history with sibo I basically now do
three big meals and then one big bedtime
snack and I need like a really big
substantial bedtime snack because I also
have insomnia so if or when I do wake up
in the night
oh dinner time oh hunger can be super
distracting so I make damn sure that
it's not the reason for me to be up in
the night so yeah I have a big snack and
I usually like to do something sweet and
something Savory I need both and I'm
gonna reveal a really strange sweet
snack that I sometimes make my husband
thinks it's super strange anyway so
leave me a comment below on whose side
you're on but I take a few whole grain
tortillas and then I scoop in some Greek
yogurt or cottage cheese whichever and
then I add some berries I put some
crunchy cereal and like nuts on top and
then I tend to roll it up the
inspiration was originally like a
makeshift no cook take on like a crepe
or like a blends but I actually end up
eating it like a taco and half the time
it squirts all over me what did he say
but it tastes really really good and
it's super stay tuning as for Savory I
usually do like salty nuts like I love
wonderful pistachios or popcorn love the
Lesser evil Himalayan sea salt one it's
so good it's made with coconut oil but
it tastes like so much more buttery than
buttery popcorn in my opinion and it
provides a lot of that saturating fiber
but if I have a bigger or later dinner
and I don't feel the need to have such a
huge super staging bedtime snack but I'm
straight up like craving something sweet
I'll just have ice cream and I don't
even need to make a Hunger crushing
combo sometimes these things are just
perfect the way they are I'm partial to
anything with like toffee or caramel or
like lots of chunks of other stuff in it
uh so yeah I basically always have
Netflix and chill in my freezer it is
pretty epic so Harvest Bazaar I have
been waiting for you to call me but like
I get that these times are super hectic
so as you can see I just went ahead and
I did all of your work for you like
saved you hundreds in editing costs
right here I mean it's so easy so like
send me an email like a DM messenger owl
whatever works I will be here I'm
waiting for that green light to be
featured on food Diaries like clearly I
know the drill so friends if you want to
see me on Harper's Bazaar send them this
video leave them comments harass them
tag them do what you gotta do internet I
have been studying this format for years
now so help your girl out oh and that is
everything I eat in a day
[Music]